c'est à mon au penthouse
j'avais deux galeries bande organisée
marie-jeanne lefebvre a été forcé de
quitter long 50 marianne est il y a
trois ans l'immeuble infestés d'insectes
et insalubres devait subir des travaux
majeurs
une rénovation comme on en voit souvent
un douloureux souvenir pour femme de 73
ans le potager albi dantec tu veux tu
perds toute immigration tu perds tu
laisses pas par avance y aller mais
c'est un arrêt pour amorcer ils ont pas
donné la chance une fois les travaux
complétés et l'aurait pu retourner par
son logement qu'il a visités et montrer
mon logement au hockey médecins cet été
faute ni le montant du loyer avait
doublé elles payer 750 $ par mois qu'un
sens l'approché se procurer l'eau non
moi je payais 515 puis je suis monté à
nice 1-2 clément a aussi fait une croix
sur le 11 50 rue marie-anne est où les
appartements fraîchement rénovés sont
désormais affichés comme des
appartements de style condo
oui à de la clientèle pour ça mais il
faut quand même que les autres puissent
habiter quelques quelque part c'est
comme si on était des déchets c'est
comme si les jacques sempé aux riches on
est des déchets le mouret novik sion
n'est pas officiellement inscrit dans la
loi mais de nombreux organismes sonne
régulièrement la larme
le phénomène prend de l'ampleur à
montréal sa part sentiment d'insécurité
ça participe à la crise du logement est
vécue actuellement à montréal et il est
urgent d'agir
le propriétaire du 11 50 marianne est
n'a pas donné suite à notre demande
d'entrevue
l'association des propriétaires du
québec rappelle que les locataires ont
des droits
le locataire le droit ont maintenant
lieu donc de la possibilité
d'augmentation de loyer skipper qui
offre beaucoup de travaux à effectuer
qui doit payer dès minuit
alors y at il une solution pour ces
intervenants
du milieu c'est au gouvernement d'agir
ça prend des dommages punitifs
exemplaire pour dissuader les
propriétaires récalcitrants
or ce n'est pas le cas actuellement il y
avait une modification au niveau des
critères d'affectation vous alliez dans
un premier temps ce serait très
bénéfique pour chacun
ça fait plusieurs années quand on arrive
à ce niveau là qu'on fait des demandes
j'espère que la situation va ouvrir les
yeux vers la mer
le ministre de l'habitation andré la
forêt se dit sensible à la question son
cabinet affirme que des travaux sont en
cours pour obliger les propriétaires à
justifier des travaux d'agrandissement
de changement d'affectation ou de
subdivision ici qui me permettrait au
canada montréal